This is the Mutual Fund factory, where
all the world’s mutual funds are produced.
Fund elves wrap stardust, lemondrops and
a nickel in a unicorn bladder, which is then
delivered via dragon-sled to brokerage firms,
who sell them to customers.
The customer buries the mutual fund in their
backyard, and after 30 or 40 years, a money
tree starts blossoming, just in time for retirement.
Babe, that’s not remotely true.
I know, but we have to get people excited
about mutual funds somehow.
They’re an important option in saving for
retirement and most people don’t even know
what they are!
Even people who own them…
like in their 401(k)s!
Wait…
401(k)s are mutual funds?
No, not exactly.
Let’s start at the beginning.
A mutual fund is kinda like... a bowl of investment
stew.
Thousands--or even millions--of investors
pool their money to buy a variety of investments
(primarily stocks, bonds and currencies) which
are blended together and then divided amongst
the participants.
And just like a restaurant serves a lot of
different dishes, mutual funds come in a lot
of different flavors…
Some funds focus on a specific sector of the
economy, like Technology, Retail or Agriculture.
Others focus on specific areas of the world
- “Emerging Markets” refers to developing
nations.
And some focus on the size of the companies
- from Large-Cap to Micro-Cap.
And they can get a lot more customized than
that: The Pax World Global Women’s Equality
Fund invests in companies that advance the
cause of gender equality.
Or, for something completely different, the
Vice Fund focuses on tobacco, alcohol, gaming,
and weapons companies.
Mutual fund shares are usually inexpensive,
and you get the advantage of diversification
without having to buy hundreds or thousands
of shares yourself.
BUT there are costs.
Every mutual fund has an upkeep fee called
an ANNUAL EXPENSE RATIO, which ranges from
around 0.1% to 2% of the value per year.
Some funds also charge an extra fee called
a LOAD when you buy or sell your shares, usually
between 1% and 5.75% of the sale price.
You can think of these fees as payment to
the chef who whipped up your dinner.
Wait… who are these chefs anyway?
And how are they deciding what ingredients
to use?
Well, that depends on whether your mutual
fund is ACTIVELY or PASSIVELY managed.
Active funds are managed by a team of analysts
and traders.
They try to out-perform the market by carefully
watching economic indicators and picking which
investments to hold and which to sell.
Kinda like a celebrity chef who’s always
improvising and changing her recipes based
on what’s trendy or in season.
As you can imagine, the fees on actively managed
funds tend to be higher.
Passive fund managers are more like chefs
who stick to the cookbook.
Their goal is to match benchmarks, not beat
them.
For example, an “S&P 500 Index Fund” tries
to mirror the modest but steady growth seen
in the index of 500 of the biggest companies.
Passive funds are popular among investors
who believe it’s a losing game to try to
“beat the market.”
Because there’s less analysis and fewer
trades, passive funds are cheaper to own.
Mutual funds are an amazing creation.
They allow ordinary people to invest like
huge institutions--thousands of holdings,
diversification--while being easy to use and
letting you express your personal tastes and
principles.
But where do you start?
If you don’t have any mutual fund investments
yet, you might begin by opening an investment
account with a mutual fund company.
Their advisors will help you choose funds
that are a good fit for your situation.
Investors who are a bit savvier and want a
more modern approach are starting to use “Robo-Advisors”
to invest in mutual funds.
Basically, you answer a few questions online
and the service automatically constructs a
personalized portfolio of funds for you and
handles all the trades and holdings.
Plus their investment minimums are pretty
low, sometimes just $100!
And if you’re invested in a 401(k) plan
through your work, you already own mutual
funds!
And you’re paying fees for an advisor, so
don’t be afraid to contact them and find
out which funds you own and what your options
are.
I remember the first time I went to a sushi
restaurant.
I didn’t recognize a lot of the ingredients
on the menu, and it was a little intimidating.
But it didn’t take me long to learn what
I liked and I’m so glad I did.
Like sushi, mutual funds may not be for everyone.
But everyone should be planning for retirement,
and mutual funds are popular with investors
of every level for good reason.
And that’s our two cents!